what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder where we talk all
things marvel and mcu i'm your host
warren thompson and kevin feige has
teased us that we are going to start to
see the connectivity of the mcu and
where the mcu is going very soon now if
you have been following and keeping up
with everything you know that marvel
studios has officially dropped that big
word that we've all been waiting to hear
mutants they have officially said the
word mutation referring to jeans in the
mcu now and a marvel executive producer
did indeed confirm mutants plus not to
mention the x-men 97 animated series
theme song that was played when the word
mutation was mentioned and of course the
ending credits confirmed this as well so
it is looking like the mutants and the
fantastic four are the future of art mcu
which is super exciting but another
thing that is really really exciting as
well are the villains that are going to
be coming with the mutants and with the
fantastic four specifically dr doom the
infamous fantastic four and marvel in
general villain and it looks like we
could be actually seeing doom a lot
sooner than we thought as early on as
the next marvel project releasing
she-hulk there is actually a major
connection to doctor doom coming up in
the she-hulk series and a big rumor
going around right now is that we are
actually going to be introduced to one
member of the fantastic four in the
she-hulk series and that is the thing
ben grimm so she-hulk might actually be
a lot bigger than we think if some of
these rumors are true and some of these
connections end up paying off it is
possible that we could get our first
introduction to the fantastic four and
to dr doom in the she-hulk series now
kevin feige also teased us that we
should be able to see the direction that
the mcu is going and from a fan's
perspective and based off of what
everybody has been saying in the
comments and on twitter and on instagram
it does seem like everybody pretty much
sees the same thing that we are headed
to secret wars the next big avengers end
game and infinity war level event except
this event will be bigger than ever
because it won't just have all of the
groups teaming up together like the
avengers the guardians spider-man but we
are going to have different variants of
them and multiple variants of them show
up as well plus not to mention the
fantastic four and the mutants so
imagine seeing all of those groups but
also seeing different variants of them
fight alongside them as well that's a
very exciting thing to be looking
forward to right now and she hulk could
also start that as well now the big
connection to avengers secret wars and
dr doom in the she-hulk series is
actually the villain titania played by
jamila jamil she actually has a direct
and very big connection to doctor doom
in the comics in fact dr doom is the
person who gives her her powers then she
fights alongside doctor doom in secret
wars let me explain how this happens now
in the comics titania's real name is
mary mcferrin and she was born
prematurely and she grew up scrawny and
short and she wasn't very wealthy in
fact she had to work a job to help
support her family and she was bullied a
lot in school by the rich kids now one
day spider woman swings by and she has
red hair of course well mary had red
hair too so she told her friend that she
was actually spider woman which of
course was a lie but her friend ended up
telling a lot of other people who told a
lot of other people and word eventually
got around that mary was spider woman so
she gets invited to a very fancy party
by the cool rich kid vanessa at her
house and she of course soon realizes
that the only reason that she got
invited was because everybody thinks
that she is spider woman then at this
time the events of secret wars battle
world happen in the middle of the party
the ground rips open and becomes a part
of the planet battle world then the real
spider woman actually shows up to try
and save people and everybody of course
realizes that mary is not spider woman
so everybody gets really mad and they
chase her and her friends into the woods
of battle world the two girls are scared
and they're alone but this is where dr
doom finds them and coincidentally
doctor doom was looking for some meta
humans that could fight alongside him
and serve him so when he finds them he
makes a deal he'll give them powers if
they serve in his army of supervillains
well mary desperately has wanted
superpowers for a very long time she has
always wanted to be a superhero and
she's wanted to be admired so it's a
pretty easy choice for the two of them
so they go back to the villain
headquarters doom base where doom uses
energy from an alien storm to give the
two girls powers now her friend ends up
getting powers being able to turn her
into a fiery form and she goes by the
name of volcano while mary essentially
got powers that were opposite of who she
was she was short and scrawny before now
she is really big and really strong
supposedly as strong as titan which is
where her name titania comes from and
from here she actually goes up against
some big foes under the commands of dr
doom she fights thor wolverine rogue and
some of the other x-men as well and
eventually she beats she-hulk causing a
very long rivalry between the two of
them which is where she comes into the
she-hulk series she is going to be the
main villain of jennifer walters aka
she-hulk and since she's going to be the
main villain of the series we should be
able to get a little bit of a backstory
about her like where she got her powers
from and why she doesn't really like
she-hulk in the series now of course
secret wars battle world has not started
in the mcu yet however as we all know
marvel doesn't just follow the comics
100 otherwise we would know everything
that was going to happen and of course
battle world hasn't happened yet so they
are going to have to retcon how exactly
she gets her powers the order of events
are obviously not going to be the same
but what can be the same is that she got
her powers from dr doom now i really
hope that this is hinted at a lot but i
do hope it's teased a lot kind of like
the mysterious employer from ant-man and
the wasp i hope it's somewhat the same i
hope they don't reveal this right away
but then by the end of the series they
reveal that the person behind titania
the person that gave her her powers is
victor von doom and i hope this goes
along with the thing popping up as well
and making the connection between the
fantastic four and doom now if you
haven't heard the rumors recently the
latest rumor states that jason seagal is
going to be playing the thing now i'm
actually a pretty big jason seagal fan
and i think that this would work keep in
mind he's gonna wear a mocap suit
whoever is gonna play the thing is going
to be playing a mocap suit the person
who plays the thing does not have to be
a very very big or buff dude even though
jason seagal is very tall but take a
look at mark ruffalo he's not really the
size of the hulk it's all mocap and we
know the mcu likes to add some comedy to
things and i think that having jason
segol play the thing would definitely
add some comedy especially when you have
a very serious mr fantastic most of the
time now the recent rumors state that
the thing is only going to communicate
with jennifer walters aka she-hulk via
his lawyer kind of like he has his own
lawyer to talk to lawyers for him but
rumor has it that jennifer walters is
going to be defending the thing in a
defamation case could this defamation
case be against victor von doom there
are obviously stories where they work
together could the mcu be playing off of
one of those stories something goes down
between them and the rest of the
fantastic fours they're all working
together and victor possibly sues seems
like a victor von doom thing to do to me
and perhaps victor von doom maybe even
gives titania her powers to go up
against the thing but instead she ends
up kind of going up against she-hulk
either way there is definitely a lot of
potential with she-hulk and its
connection to doctor doom and if these
rumors are true it could introduce the
fantastic four keep in mind miss marvel
we didn't really expect to be anything
huge as far as the big reveals are
concerned but at the very last scene of
the very last episode they name-dropped
mutants so it could be that in she-hulk
they could introduce the fantastic four
plus not to mention san diego comic-con
is next week and then it is followed up
by d23 where we're expecting some pretty
big reveals from marvel studios and
since the last thing kevin feige said in
the last 2019 san diego comic-con was
the mutants and the fantastic four we're
expecting an update but in the meantime
let me know what you think about this
connection to doctor doom and the rumors
about the thing showing up in she-hulk
be sure to let me know in the comments
down below don't forget to like the
video and subscribe so you don't miss
out on any of the latest videos and for
live updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter as always thank
you all so much for watching woof
you